let's talk about the herb ashwagandha I
really like this herb I use it in one of
my adrenal formulas and it's really good
for stress so let's just kind of go
through what it can do the main effect
of this herb has to do with this final
chemical called with analytes okay this
phytochemical and there's quite a few of
them I think there's like 300 different
types is a steroid compound interesting
because your Drina glands are also made
from steroids and ashwagandha has been
around for a very very long time at
least 3,000 years it's an adaptogen so
it helps you adapt encounter stress now
of course the best thing to do is to
isolate where that stress is coming from
or who is causing the stress and deal
with that because I've noticed them even
when I was in practice that unless you
really fix the stress you can keep
taking vitamins and herbs all the time
and it'll help a tiny bit but you really
have to find the source of where that's
coming from
I know presently there's a lot of fear
going on related to a virus and the
problem with that is a very interesting
problem because you have this thing
which is being promoted to be everywhere
you have to avoid it it's invisible and
once you get it you can die so the best
thing if you have that fear is to learn
more about it be educated on your immune
system strengthen the immune system and
that way you can be bulletproof against
that threat and the reason I'm bringing
that up is just because the fear itself
has an emotion can literally [__] the
immune system it can make you more
susceptible to getting the virus and I
will put some videos down that talk
about how to strengthen your immune
system it has anti-inflammatory
properties so it's really good for
arthritis and autoimmune conditions but
of course anything that I say in here is
not meant to diagnose or give you a
treatment for an illness check with your
doctor I'm just talking about the
effects that this could potentially
create anti-anxiety
has immuno regulatory so it's good for
the immune system because it's lowering
stress and stress is probably the worst
thing for the immune system and I
already mentioned how to write a tsunami
it also can potentially lower your
cortisol which is behind the stress it
can actually help your blood sugars it
can improve insulin sensitivity and most
people take Ostrow ganda simply for this
to lower their stress and anxiety and
wednesday there was an improvement of 69
percent versus only 11 percent in a
placebo trial i'll put the link down
below and also as far as you mood it can
potentially improve depression another
study that I read there was a 79 percent
improvement versus a 10 percent
improvement for a placebo so that's
pretty significant it also has a
potential for increasing testosterone
that may relate to improving muscle
strength and even muscle mass because
testosterone is connected with that by
the way the more stress that you have
the more cortisol that's elevated the
less testosterone you're gonna have okay
we already mentioned the
anti-inflammatory effects better brain
function better focus because you're
less stressed decrease pain and improve
sleep so ashwagandha is an incredible
herb to improve your stress and it has
very minimal side effects if any all
right if you want more information about
how to bulletproof your immune system I
put it right here check it out